well ending school violence it's an
initiative that a group of dads are
taking on in fact just last month the
ccsd board of trustees approved the dads
in schools program but now they are
overwhelmed with just how many schools
need their help victoria saha joins us
now live with more on this story
victoria
dads in schools volunteers are getting
excited to step into the classrooms but
with over 70 schools wanting their help
they need your help to grow their team
the hope of seeing more father figures
in ccsd school hallways is getting
closer to reality hundreds of volunteers
have already signed up to be dads in
schools but they need hundreds more we
currently need
700 740 men
just to cover the 74 schools that have
requested founder of dads in schools
troy martinez is grateful the school
board approved their group at a time
where violence has been such a hot topic
for our schools it's encouraging to see
the community as we expected to be vegas
strong and rise up in time of need
and be there to see healing and to
further protect
their students it's a good long-term
program
for disruptive students
who need
the extra attention to help them not be
so disruptive and although many parents
are excited for this
not everyone is on board with the
program some worry about unlicensed
volunteers on campuses
if you would like to volunteer to be a
dad in school we have a link up on our
website at 8newsnow.com martinez says
every volunteer has to go through a
background check which will take about
three weeks victoria saha live local now